[Musique]
conformément à leurs engagements du 6
juillet dernier la présidente de région
et le président du département signé la
convention d'application du dispositif
visant à réduire le prix de vente de la
bouteille de gaz à la réunion une
signature qui s'est déroulée ce vendredi
29 juillet en présence du préfet jacques
billant et des compagnies pétrolières
nous devons faire preuve de
responsabilité face à la vie chère à la
baisse du pouvoir d'achat des
réunionnaises et des réunionnais surtout
des familles les plus fragiles et bien
région département nous devons faire
preuve de responsabilité
poids étaient ces mêmes familles et donc
nous avons signé une belle convention
qui engage la région comme le
département a apporté une contribution
de 5 millions d'euros
en tout 10 millions pour faire en sorte
de la bouteille de gaz et bien soit
maintenu que son prix soit maintenu à 15
euros c'est une aide publique sur fonds
publics associé à un effort et je le
demande des entreprises qui distribuent
donc ce même bouteille de gaz et donc il
faut pas l'oublier cette convention à
saussines région département bien
évidemment mais aussi les acteurs
économiques de la filière distribution
de gaz ici à la réunion donc un élan de
solidarité
une chaîne de solidarité
s'est construite autour du pouvoir
d'achat la réunion et donc le
département prend toute sa place et le
participant à l'effort collectif
grâce à la mobilisation financière
conjointe du conseil régional et du
conseil départemental estimé à 10
millions d'euros les familles
réunionnaises et les entreprises vont
bénéficier dès ce lundi 1er août d'une
bouteille de gaz à un prix de 15 euros
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2022
[Musique]